il est à peu près 23 heures locales
quand un puissant séisme frappe le Maroc
d'ici à Marrakech des touristes fils au
restaurant dans les rues de la ville la
panique et des dégâts importants
jusqu'à ce que la terre se met à
trembler
la panique gagne les habitants ils
courent dans tous les sens certains
d'entre eux stupéfaits voient leurs
courses dévier par dessous d'un
éboulement
d'autres sont probablement pris au piège
sous les décombres parfois la survie
s'est jouée à quelques secondes cette
femme vient tout juste de sortir de chez
elle quand son immeuble s'effondre
un nuage de poussière envahit cette
ruelle
c'est pas souvent l'occasion de la
mettre
[Musique]